und bei mir nix tagesgespräch ist die
bundesvorsitzende der jusos jessica
rosenthal gleichzeitig gewählt in den
neuen deutschen bundestag über die
landesliste nordrhein westfalen mit sitz
hier in bonn hier hatten sie sich um ein
direktmandat beworben sind aber der
grünen kollegin knapp mit nur 216
stimmen unterlegen die ampel auf
bundesebene das wäre eine premiere was
können die jusos dazu tun damit es
gelingt vor rosenthal naja erstmal haben
wir schon eine ganze menge getan wir
haben nämlich dieses zukunftsprogramm
was die spd verabschiedet hat und für
das wir auch gewählt worden sind mit
gestaltet werden unsere punkte dort mit
eingebracht und wir haben sehr sehr
viele junge kandidierende aufgestellt
die vor ort alles gegeben haben um
diesen weg möglich zu machen und wo
immerhin 49 von den über 80 die
kandidiert haben auch eingezogen sind
und von daher glaube ich haben wir schon
eine ganze menge beigetragen dafür dass
überhaupt in dieser sehr guten
ausgangslage sind dass wir den
regierungsauftrag bekommen haben und so
viel vertrauen von wählerinnen und
wählern erhalten haben für das wäre auch
immer noch sehr dankbar sind also der
hinweis sozusagen auf eine gewisse mann
starke innerhalb der spd
bundestagsfraktion ist ja auch durchaus
etwas worüber später nochmal darauf
zurückkommen können was wir erlebt haben
jetzt an diesem wochenende ist dass alle
jugend formationen sage ich mal mit
forderungen an die jeweiligen verhandler
oder sagen wir mal so ein dealer sind es
ja im moment noch herangetreten sind
welche gesprächsfäden gibt es denn
eigentlich zwischen den parteien jugend
also zwischen julis zwischen jusos und
der grünen jugend na ja es ist schon so
dass wir uns natürlich in gewisser weise
auch als vertreterinnen und vertretern
von der generation verstehen gerade mit
der grünen jugend haben wir sehr sehr
enge drähte auch über einen langen
zeitraum schon das ist quasi
aufgewachsen
aber es ist auch so dass wir natürlich
auch mit den julis sprechen es gibt
programmatische unterschiede
insbesondere zwischen judes und julis
ich glaube das ist ein klar aber
trotzdem ist es uns wichtig im
miteinander zu sprechen und auch zu
gucken wo sind vielleicht
gemeinsamkeiten nun ist er
sondierungsteam die sechs personen von
der spd seine formation 50plus wenn wir
jetzt mal herrn klingbeil herausnehmen
sie haben jetzt hier schon in den
letzten tagen mehrfach bekundet dass die
jusos da nicht am katzentisch sitzen
wollen wenn es dann tatsächlich zu
koalitionsverhandlungen kommt
mitarbeiten wollen wie soll das konkret
aussehen welche expertise können sie
dann einbringen naja also erstmal ist es
sozusagen keine forderung sondern eine
selbstverständlichkeit ich beschreibe
von daher sehe ich das auch gar nicht
als so einen revolutionären akt an
sondern wenn wir uns angucken wo die spd
steht wie die jusos mit gestalten wie
wir auch im verändere bundestagsfraktion
vertreten sind ist das normalste der
welt dass wir sagen wir wollen auch
dabei sein wie können ganze menge an
expertise einbringen nicht nur durch die
die jetzt gewählt worden sind sondern
auch durch den verband der ja
programmatisch die spd mit blick auf die
letzten jahre auch mit aufgestellt hat
und dass wir dann sagen wir wollen uns
gerade auch für die anliegen unserer
generation aber auch für unsere
gesellschaftliche analyse die wir auch
haben als jusos und als richtungs
verband einsetzen ist glaube ich auch
nichts jetzt also nichts und nichts was
man nicht auch fordern kann oder was
nicht selbstverständlich sei das heißt
wir dürfen erwarten das ist jetzt nicht
nur für die stimme der jugend denn wir
haben ja dort schon relativ reife
gesellschaft also die sozusagen die die
oma findet bei ihnen auch irgendwo statt
natürlich wir sind doch nicht angetreten
um die generationen gegeneinander
auszuspielen und das finde ich auch sehr
falsch und gegenteil ich erlebe dass
ganz viele ältere menschen sagen es muss
jetzt endlich auch mal junge menschen
geben die ihre stimme erheben die sich
einsetzen für den klimaschutz die sich
einsetzen für ihre generation also es
gibt keinen gegeneinander es gibt
immerhin miteinander aber damit es
dieses miteinander geben kann braucht es
immer beide seiten und das was in der
deutschen politik sehen ist ein jugend
defizit und daher sage ich klar das
müssen auch die parteien beheben und wir
als spd haben dann massiven schritt nach
vorne gemacht
es gibt ja verschiedene punkte die wir
jetzt alle sozusagen durchdeklinieren
könnten je nachdem wie lange das
gespräch ist 30 40 oder 120 minuten aber
wenn wir uns mal auf zwei punkte
vielleicht mal konzentrieren sie hatten
kürzlich noch mal sich nordrhein
westfalen bietet sich an rund um die
kohleverstromung geäußert und hat man
sich gesagt sie würden sich wünschen
vielleicht sogar fordern das müssen sie
jetzt mal konkretisieren bitte dass der
ausstieg bereits vor 20 38 gelingt das
wäre ja noch eine leichte differenz auch
zu dem was die sozusagen offizielle
parteilinie war bunt sie sich konkret
auf eine zahl festlegen
nein ich hab das was ich deutlich
gemacht hat ist dass die
kohleverstromung und die emissionen die
dadurch entstehen natürlich ein sachsen
sind wo wir ganz ganz viel in kurzer
zeit gewinnen können um dem klimawandel
wirklich entgegen zu treten um massiv
ihn auch zu bekämpfen klar ist auch wir
brauchen eine versorgungssicherheit und
ich bin in keiner weise irgendwie im
gegensatz zu meiner partei sondern wir
sagen ja auch spätestens 38 ich sage
aber klar auch aus meiner jungen
perspektive muss früher sein aber ich
halte nichts davon jahreszahlen
festzulegen die man dann nicht einhalten
kann sondern es muss machbar sein aber
das ziel muss sein es deutlich früher zu
schaffen wenn sie sagen muss nicht
unbedingt eine festlegung sein würde
dass möglicherweise auch so was für eine
frage wie tempolimits auf autobahnen war
ja auch so ein großer ideologie punkt im
wahlkampf muss nicht unbedingt sein
haben wir sie richtig verstanden also
auch da ist es so ist alles was für das
die spd steht für das wir auch als jusos
stehen also viele punkte von denen
stehen im zukunftsprogramm und da steht
drin wir sind für ein tempolimit von 130
auf autobahnen
aber wir regieren hier nicht alleine wir
wollen auf augenhöhe verhandeln und wir
wollen kompromisslinien finden und
deshalb ich kann ich ihnen nicht sagen
ob es eine kompromisslinie sein kann
dieses tempolimit durchzusetzen oder ob
die fdp sich so massiv sperrt das sie
sagt das ist mit uns nicht zu machen das
sind ja genau da ist ja genau das was
jetzt in den gesprächen weiter
ausgelotet werden soll und wo ich auch
vollstes vertrauen habe dass dort gute
linien versucht werden zu finden was mir
wichtig ist als junge generation ist
dass wir endlich über sachthemen
sprechen dass es wirklich darum geht
große würfe zu machen und nicht so klein
klein verhackstückt lungen sind die dann
in formelkompromissen enden die uns dann
als gesellschaft und als junge
generation nicht voranbringen nicht dass
jeder nur ein bisschen bekommt am ende
und irgendetwas hochhalten kann für die
klientel einer der sozusagen kernpunkte
wir gerade weil sie die generationen
nochmal ansprechen ist ja die frage wie
man sich bei der steuer und
finanzpolitik irgendwie am ende auf
stellt da sind die linien am weitesten
voneinander entfernt am ende geht es
aber auch darum deutschland hat sehr
viel geld in die hand genommen und wer
wüsste das besser als ihr
kanzlerkandidat und finanzminister und
wir haben sozusagen unsere verschuldungs
kurve noch mal massiv gestreikt die
frage ist wollen wir da jetzt wirklich
weitermachen und dann so eine
schuldenbremse wieder aufweichen na ja
das was mir wichtig ist ist dass wir
nicht nur auf den kontostand schauen wir
haben nämlich nicht nur schulden im
konto auf dem konto stand sondern
massive schulden in unserer
infrastruktur ich habe als lehrerin die
letzten anderthalb jahre mitschülerinnen
und dieses landes gesehen was das
bedeutet was es bedeutet für
chancengleichheit in diesem land ich
habe es auch gesehen mit blick auf den
umbau der industrie da haben wir
jahrelang viel zu wenig getan und müssen
jetzt schauen dass wir überhaupt den
anschluss halten dass wir als industrie
nationen auch zeigen dass man aus kohle
atom aussteigen kann und gleichzeitig
industriestandort bleiben kann deshalb
braucht es massive investition das ist
auch generationengerechtigkeit jetzt zu
investieren und wie das dann geht ob man
die schuldenbremse anfasst oder nicht
das kann ich ihnen auch heute nicht
sagen weil ich noch nicht weiß welche
kompromisslinien man findet das
investiert werden muss das steht für
mich außer frage vielleicht etwas
anderes was wir ganz eindeutig mit ja
oder nein beantworten können bei einer
kanzlerwahl das ist jetzt zukunftsmusik
aber sie habe gerade auf die 49 stimmen
hingewiesen die jusos wollten ja herrn
scholz nicht als portal vorsitzenden
aber als kanzler würden sie ihn betreten
wir haben massiv wahlkampf gemacht für
olaf scholz und als unseren
kanzlerkandidaten erst der richtige
gewesen für dieses land er ist jetzt
auch der richtige der deutschland und
auch unsere generation vertreten kann
auf internationaler bühne der das land
mit voranbringen kann da bin ich ganz
sicher der auch dafür beitrag zu
beitragen wird dass die punkte die uns
wichtig sind durchgesetzt werden und
deshalb werden wir mit voller
überzeugung unser kreuz bei olaf scholz
als unserem kanzler machen und ich es
wird für mich und für die jusos ein sehr
grosser moment sein wenn wir wieder eine
sozialdemokratisch geführte regierung
haben das steht auch für uns außer frage
ok im fall des falles 49 stimmen aus der
spd fraktion von den jusos vielen dank
dass sika rosenthal die
juso-bundesvorsitzende und neu gewählte
bundestagsabgeordnete für das phoenix
tagesgespräch dargestellt ich denke
ihnen